a fine game by lanier uh near this game
was
a long one definitely you had to go to
work what did you feel were your chances
coming out the opening
uh well it's a very solid opening so i i
was just trying to
equalize of course first but then i
think i got uh
some chances i think uh bishop h4 was
was a bit careless i think
it gave me
the chance to play this queen h5 and
let's let's get it on yasser's board if
you don't mind yeah it's there
yes uh we we agree with you
wholeheartedly linear we thought that
bishop and
alejandro was the first to say ooh
i'm not
liking that move and after queen h5
please continue yeah i think at least uh
i mean black is of course very safe and
and and i was able to create some on
balance in the position
so
uh at least i could put pressure and uh
yeah i think after h5 there is
it's always a bit uncomfortable for for
the white king because there is
knight g4 everywhere and he cannot
really move the the pawns on the king
side
i think still the position it's it's
probably nothing too serious but uh
already white is i think it's under
under some pressure here
all right at a certain moment uh there
was a repetition was that just because
of the
time
situation on the clocks before you
played c5 you broke off the repetition
with the move c5 yeah i just wanted to
uh
get uh closer to the to the time control
before i
but it was clear that i that i would
play on because
at this point already white's position
is
it's very unpleasant
so you consider this position to be very
unpleasant here we
we thought that you were better we just
didn't know how
serious it was uh yeah i think uh
here
he was
in time travel and maybe i think around
140 maybe i could i felt that i was
very close to just winning on the spot
so i don't know if uh
uh yeah like around here when i took on
before and yeah here it feels like it's
winning maybe queenie won i don't know
if queenie one was immediately winning
queen e1 queen f1 i mean instead of a3
uh
but i couldn't
calculate uh
till the end i also had like
less than one minute
uh yeah and then maybe something like
queen c3 because if i take king takes
knight e4
king e2 and
a3
yeah something like this is also maybe
winning because he has to play king d3
and then i take on f2
king c3
uh knight e4 king b4
then take on g3 and knight back to f5
it should be weird
it's a lot of fun that feels good yeah
and also queen c3 i mean after queenie
one queen f1 i think queen c3 also looks
extremely strong
so just uh pardon me just in this moment
a lot to be said for this continuation
what you're just mentioning in
queensland looks very good for you also
because a3 knight e4 is coming and pawn
on d4 is also hanging and
it should be winning so i think a3 um
was a bit
inaccurate but uh it's probably still
winning because it's
yeah
here i would i mean taking upon with
check i'm not the one to argue against
that move but here it also felt like
queen d3 with a similar thing what
you've just shown
just take them and uh you know just
bring your knight to the square you pick
up this by the time white's over here
yeah picking up the pawn on a3 you're
picking up g3 and
yeah so that would have been pretty okay
but you took the pawn
and then you found out it wasn't that
easy until
hurry thought you missed a moment
uh right idea wrong execution you played
queen cc
seven with the move h4
h4 first time
i even saw it but uh
yeah if he takes then check on a2 and
correct yeah that's just too easy right
yeah jack and a2
so we thought we would get dinner and
this we got cold sandwiches
yeah somehow i made it too difficult
well you did win a fine game i like to
ask on a from a psychological
perspective when you're playing a
low-rated player he's the lowest-rated
player in the field do you feel like you
know even though i have black
got to press this player
well i um as i said i wasn't really
trying to win from the start or anything
like that for sure i was just trying to
equalize but
i of course wanted to to
to get some
on balance in the position if if i had
the chance and
maybe petrov is not the best opening in
the world to to get that but uh
at some point uh i knew i could get some
chances and i i was i was ready to to
use them my final question for you
opportunity to play in the sink field
cup doesn't come along every single year
big aspirations for this tournament
uh
well i the main thing is just to
try to to play to play well to play good
games i'm sure
if i manage to to
play at my best level or close to that
the result is not going to be bad so
my last tournament didn't go so well
the world cup in russia i mean i got to
play only two classical games i didn't
play that bad but the result was was bad
because i i was knocked out in the first
round
so the main thing is just to try to
play well and
hopefully i can get a good result at the
end we're looking forward to seeing you
at your best congratulations on the win
today thank you good luck in the rest of
your games thank you absolutely linear
well done